today we're going to be speaking with
the president and CEO of Media Matters
Angelo carusone we're going to talk
about uh well many many different things
Angelo it's great to have you on I
appreciate it likewise thank you so to
start with
there is a feeling that Fox News in
particular and maybe some other
right-wing media are starting to set up
a little bit of like an eject button or
an escape hatch were Donald Trump not to
be the Republican nominee in 2024 Fox
News ran like a man on the street
segment where they had a bunch of people
saying oh no if it was up to me it would
be DeSantis who's the nominee they're
not really against Trump but it feels as
though they're setting up an escape
hatch is that your sense of what's going
on
yeah I think that's a really I like the
way that you put it because a lot of
people oftentimes put it like they've
turned on Trump right oh that's that's a
little extreme
um but the escape hatch is the right way
to think about it which is that you know
one of the things that has happened and
is that you know in the past Trump sort
of captured Fox news's audience and was
able to really LeapFrog Fox News and
speak directly to them and then the
audience you know kind of forced Fox to
align that's how he captured them he
seized it yep he doesn't have the same
tools available to him there's opposing
candidates like DeSantis that helped
create some of that friction so what
they're basically doing is hedging um
and I would just remind everyone that
this is a very similar posture that Fox
News was in and poor place
um in 2015. you know in 2015 they had
the Fox News primary where you would
have candidates that would get a ton of
attention that would be the flavor of
the two weeks and they would shoot to
the top and there was people criticizing
Trump on air on network you know there
was factions within Fox that had
different people that they supported and
I think that's starting to emerge right
now I also think you know they're trying
to they're hedging because it's not
clear that Trump is going to be able to
replicate what he did in 20 in 2016 and
they kind of know it so escape hatch is
exactly the right way to put it to go
back to 2015 2016 there was that early
period where Fox was very much not on
the Trump train and as you say
ultimately they did acquiesce is there
anything about the backstory of the
relationship between Trump and the
murdochs that is relevant to how that
went or or was that not a factor in your
mind
it was not so much of a factor it was
really about Roger rails um the only
thing that was relevant at the time
about the murdochs is that Rupert
Murdoch has always wanted Fox to really
have a president like like not to just
have an alliance with the president you
know they were obviously aligned with
the Bush Administration
um but there was a they were two
different entities that sort of had some
Synergy and Alignment what Murdoch is
always fantasized about uh has been to
really create a president uh or you know
a world leader but really a president
and so what when ales started to put
more of the you know Fox News behind
Trump as things started to seem to break
in his favor
um Murdoch really saw that as an
opportunity to create something and
that's where he sort of said okay I'm
all in now uh and then he cashed in on
those favors as soon as Trump got into
office right by doing some pretty
outrageous things trying to get him to
slow down the deals so that he could
muck with and maybe even buy CNN and you
know it really it that was the
determining Factor but it wasn't until
after it was pretty clear that Trump
could capture the nomination that
Murdoch said okay we can go all in now
before the FBI search at Mar-A-Lago
there was this stretch of time where
Trump was just gone from Fox News he was
doing and still is doing interviews
where oftentimes he's just literally
phoning it in channels that nobody's
heard of and you know it seemed as
though maybe this was a sign that his
star is fading after the search there
was the entire the Sean Hannity
interview which by the way was a total
total disaster didn't really do anything
good for him but put that aside for a
second was there something to that
absence from Fox News in your mind there
was
um now they still talked about him nine
to 10 15 times more than anybody else
yeah but there was something to it two
things actually one was that was the
beginning of the January 6 hearings and
there was all of this information coming
out testimony where you know there was
actually you know Fox News hosts were
part of it where they were actually
texting and talking so it complicated
things a little bit it and then the
second thing and this is really
important is that the defamation lawsuit
that from Dominion which is that voting
machine company that's suing Fox News
for a billion dollars
um they had been arguing for almost
seven eight months that the murdochs
would not be part of it
and just in the beginning of the summer
uh it was the the courts ruled that
actually the murdochs will be a part of
this litigation and what that meant is
that fox Executives in the murdochs were
trying to demonstrate that oh there's
some distance between us and Trump
um and there was a little bit of back
and forth over that summer as they
started to calibrate their legal
strategy so I think it was really those
two things coming together which is
let's keep him at arm's length because
every time he appears on our Network
he's either it's either going to create
a new round of stories about the our
hopes for January 6 or it's going to
complicate the back end stuff that we're
dealing with with this massive billion
dollar lawsuit so what I want to get off
Fox after one more question and get onto
some other right-wing media Outlets but
at this point do you have a sense of
who's more powerful within the
Republican base in terms of trump or Fox
News in the sense of if Trump says I'm
running and fox did decide we actually
want to prevent Trump from being the
nominee who who is the power right now
Tucker Tucker okay specifically yeah
it's just Tucker
um and so uh the rest of fox would have
to would break for Trump at this point
Fox would be able to capture uh Trump
would be able to hijack the fox audience
and we're seeing that play out a little
bit right now with the attacks on Pelosi
Posey's husband you know Fox initially
treated like a traditional crime story
and then after sort of the Trump part of
the ecosystem was weaving conspiracies
all of a sudden Fox News sort of broke
and went with the conspiracy Direction
so there's lots of indicators like that
um so if Fox was against Trump trump
would win that fight but if Tucker is
then Trump is in trouble because Tucker
really has replaced Limbaugh as sort of
like the what he used to describe as the
titular head of the Republican Party
Tucker has really filled that space so
Trump V Fox Trump trump V Tucker Tucker
what do you make of
um recently even Newsmax I so the way I
put some of these on a spectrum is
you've got Fox which is on the right and
then you've got Newsmax which is crazier
than Fox and then you've got oan which
is crazier than Newsmax that I sort of
have them like that and you can tell me
whether you agree or disagree Newsmax
recently is not even taking all of
Donald Trump's rallies they still take
most of them but not all of them does
that mean that even within the even
crazier Wing maybe Trump star is fading
a little bit and it's also you know it's
a little complicated too because they um
a lot some other entities went out there
and really cornered that market of the
rallies live so um you know Trump's own
lawyer hosts yeah right side
broadcasting right I mean when there so
I mean they have an inside track um Fox
News actually has an entire channel on
their Fox Nation app that they will give
away free trials for so they use the
Trump rallies to get more people to sign
up
um the entire section is devoted to just
Trump's rallies so they kind of others
got into the space to try to
commercialize it so I think there's a
financial like Corner in the market
Factor but I look at the metrics you
know they see that you know the rallies
don't have the same juice and star power
that they did in the past and for
Newsmax which has slightly thinner
margins
um it doesn't get them the same bang for
the buck and also every time he says
something about the election they have
to worry about their channels and
getting Zapped and so if for them it's
just it's just not worth it so you
talked a little bit about the Trump
versus someone else Primary in terms of
Tucker and the power dynamics there but
if we zoom out a little and even like
separate it maybe from from Fox News how
do you believe right-wing media more
generally will handle if it's Trump
DeSantis because I don't think DeSantis
can be written off as a rhino in the
same way that they do with like Mitt
Romney for example so what do you think
they're going to come up with for
covering such a primary it's going to be
really hard there's two complicating fat
there's two big considerations one is
that um DeSantis has a pretty potent
piece of like Kryptonite uh that he
started to deploy which is vaccines and
it started over the summer and he
started to basically you know he's been
apologizing for saying that he he was
misled he should have never promoted the
vaccines it's it's probably the only
wedge where he can really successfully
outflank Trump
um on to the right and and have
credibility with the right-wing media
and that's what it's about it's about
sort of hijacking the right or
outflanking Trump when it comes to some
of these right-wing personalities to say
look at DeSantis you know he's willing
to accept the fact that he should have
known he's been anti-vaxx and he's
anti-state control and we're free you
know Liberty and you know he did it a
little bit over the summer and it worked
um it changed the way right-wing media
talked about them that's when Alex Jones
started to really hit Donald Trump was
on the vaccine stuff and then you could
look at a bunch of these right-wing
media hosts that were saying oh Trump's
going to have to Grapple with this at
some point why won't he just say he was
lied to why won't he apologize about
this he's so stubborn and so Santa
started to you know basically deploy it
as a trial balloon did it for about six
weeks and he walked it back so I think
one is how heavily he leans into that
and how Trump navigates that is a
weakness because Trump's base is not
with Trump on this and that is this
weird tension where he's out of step
with them
um and so that's one and I think that
will affect the way the media lines up
because it will give them cover to then
criticize Trump in a way that doesn't
get them blow back from their own
audiences
um is to get him on that terrain so
that's that's one part and then the
other part is is actually a knock
against DeSantis is that DeSantis is no
fun
so the truth is nobody really likes him
that's what everyone's hedging on and
I'm not trying to be mean or glib about
it it's the truth he really is no fun
even his closest allies acknowledge that
he's genuinely no fun he's aloof he's
not charismatic he's and if you're in
the media you need to think about the
product
um and what's the sustaining and staying
power and that's the challenge with
DeSantis is that I think from the media
perspective they're all aware of the
fact that DeSantis doesn't have the same
you sort of like regenerative power in
terms of media consumption in the way
that that Trump does so it's this weird
thing but I I do think the vaccine piece
is going to really be challenging and
Trump is going to take a lot of flack
for that from the right-wing media and
if they want to jump that's going to be
their launch pad last thing I want to
ask you about what is the timing of the
2024 Primary getting going because some
part of me thinks it gets going on
November 9th quite frankly
yeah I think you're right um I have
always been pointing to the fact that um
there's no way that Trump would announce
a candidacy until his airplane was ready
and uh it was supposed to be ready back
in July but of course because of all the
supply chain issues pieces of it weren't
complete and the timeline got radically
disrupted it is now officially finished
there's no way that he would run for
president without his plane it's too
it's too much of an important part of
the staging right
um and so it's just it was an obvious to
me it just felt very obvious that he
couldn't be a candidate without his
plane it doesn't work
um and and so that's to me uh if this
plane wasn't ready I would say we have
to wait uh but because his plane is now
ready I agree with you I think it's
going to start almost immediately after
November 9th and that ties into what's
happening now because a lot of what's
happening on the ground the
infrastructure at the state level a lot
of the organizations the the cluster of
groups that are going to get power or
potentially get power if the election
goes in their favor this is all part of
the Trump ecosystem that has been
building this groundwork so it's going
to almost be at the Apex and a lot of
momentum for him to make a quick jump I
and he's also seen to the extent that
they're going to challenge any elections
he's really the face of that strategy
and approach so I think you're right
it's going to start very very very early
and it sounds like from the language
you're using you have no doubt
whatsoever that Trump is running
yeah I think he's going to run for sure
um uh I do I don't think there's any
reason to stop him from running and uh
he is fueled in large part by Spite and
revenge and every measurable indicator
still shows that he could succeed in the
primary he his assessment of DeSantis is
that he is too miserable of a person to
successfully High to replace him as the
head of the party
um and uh DeSantis I think is gonna I
think he's a little hesitant to get too
bloodied up by Trump
um because it can be a messy battle so
there is a little bit of a delicate
Balancing Act there
um but yeah I do I think for a lot of
reasons there's no there's no doubt that
he will in my mind that he will run
unless there's some major intervening
circumstance this is really the last
thing and then I'll let you go
um it it seems very clear that there's a
lot of people in right-wing media right
now and even some of the candidates
starting to prepare for if we lose it
was rigged but we also know that that
caused significant legal problems for a
lot of media when they did it with 2020
what do you expect on November 9th 10th
11th as far as that story goes
yeah I think the thing that I would just
point out I'm glad you asked this is
that um because it demonstrated to be a
challenge they've adapted and well the
way that they adapted was by building an
infrastructure of these groups and
entities that they'll be able to cite
and reference and they're disposable so
you could say so they can say this group
makes this claim and they filed this
lawsuit exactly yeah exactly and so they
really and there's a lot of centers
about 14 of them in operation right now
they're promoting all these apps that
help collect this information most of
them are disposable they're not
infrastructure they're not designed to
have staying power they're shells and
that was a way that and they've done
little ones at the major States there's
one in Pennsylvania there's one in
Arizona they're all tied into right-wing
media they get a lot of attention a lot
of press a lot of Engagement a lot of
audience traction they've been bumping
pumping them up now for about about 10
months and so that's the workaround is
that they found a way to essentially
create a shield so that the media
operations can engage in the same kinds
of attacks but now they have this layer
of cover they'll never get sued for
citing a third party organization a
third-party organization can get sued
um but they won't that was Fox's problem
you know in in 20 in 2016 2020 is that
they were just saying these things that
they were getting texted you know they
were the source and now they've really
found a way to to create that and I
think that is the one thing that I don't
think people broadly have a full handle
on is that they've built the
infrastructure to actually do what they
did in 2020 but at scale in a much more
professional way uh and in a much more
uh scale and much more volume yeah slick
and scary at the same time I guess I
would say but we've been speaking with
the president and CEO of Media Matters
Angelo Carrison always uh great to talk
to you and appreciate your insights
thanks for having me